the Hindu god Vishnu is the protector of
creation and angle Wat was built for him
inside the temple are over 12,000 square
feet of intricately carved reliefs one
relief was created to linked Kings who
of arm and the second to Vishnu himself
look you can see that by relief the king
who build this temple and if you look
closely over there there is an
inscription saying prayer comedy an
onion which rhombic Brahma Brahma Vishnu
oka meaning that he is the king who went
to the highest world of Vishnu
[Music]
archaeologists aren't sure whether the
king is buried here but local people
believe that his spirit resides here in
dish news paradise that paradise that
heaven lies at the top of the central
tower as I believe that the story of
Amon the second spirit would inhabit
these powers again I authorize exactly
if you look at this tip you know like
the wise of the supply is to Narrows you
know like it can be implied the ideas of
Fatima approaching the words of God is
not that easy
all right well what what's not wait a
moment longer let's let's go up please
go
[Music]
the peak of the temple would believed by
the Khmer to be the highest reaches of
heaven and the realm of Vishnu himself
there with what do you think I think
that everyone is impressed by your
ancestors is phenomenal perhaps they
were building such immaculate beautiful
structures to entice the gods to inhabit
these structures so that the priest the
king would have had this opportunity to
have a direct connection with the
supernatural yet true even if you're not
a spiritual person you can feel the aura
of this kind of place and you know we
really are at heaven on earth
[Music]